you've now learned about several highly
effective neural network and confident
architectures what I want to do in the
next few videos to share view some
practical advice on how to use them
first starting with using open source
implementations it turns out that a lot
of these neural networks are difficult
or finicky to replicate because the lot
of details about tuning of the hyper
parameters such as learning rate decay
and other things that make some
difference to the performance and so I
found that is sometimes difficult even
for say AI or deep learning PhD students
even at the top universities to
replicate someone else's published work
just from reading the research paper
fortunately a lot of deep learning
researchers routinely open-source their
work on the internet such as on github
and as you do work yourself I certainly
encourage you to consider contributing
back your code to the open source
community but if you see a research
paper whose results you would like to
build on top of one thing you should
consider doing one thing I do quite
often is just look online for an open
source implementation because if you can
get the author's implementation you can
usually get going much faster than in
order to try to re-implement it from
scratch although certainly
re-implementing from scratch could be a
good exercise to do as well if you're
already familiar with how to use github
this video might be less necessary or
less important for you but if you aren't
used to downloading open source code
from github let me quickly show you how
easy it is let's say you've heard about
let's say you're excited about residual
networks and you want to use it so let's
search for residents on github and so
you actually see a lot of different
implementations of resinous on github
I'm just going to go to the first URL
here and this is a good huh repo that
implements resinous along with the
github web pages if you scroll down
we'll have some text describing the work
or the particular implementation
on this weekly repo disfigure to github
repo repository was actually by the
original authors of the ResNet paper and
this code this license under MIT license
you can click through to take a look at
the implications of this license the MIT
license is one of the more permissive or
one of the more open open-source
licenses so I'm gonna go ahead and
download the code and to do that click
on this link this gives you the URL that
you can use to download the code I'm
gonna click this button over here to
copy the URL to my clipboard and then go
over here and all you have to do is type
git clone and then control V for the URL
and hit enter and so in a couple seconds
as download it as clones this repository
to my local hard disk so let's go into
the directory let's take a look
I'm more used to magnet windows but I
guess let's see let's go to proto Tex
and I think this is where it has the
files specifying the network so let's
take a look at this file because there's
a very long file that specifies the
detailed configurations of the ResNet
with a hundred and one layers right and
it looks like you know from what I
remember seeing from this webpage this
Picard implementation uses the cafe
framework but they wanted implementation
of this code using some other
programming framework you might go to
find it as well so if you are developing
a computer vision application a very
common workflow would be to make an
architecture that you like maybe one of
the ones you learn about in this course
or maybe one that you heard about from a
friend or from some literature and look
for an open-source implementation and
download it from github to start
building from there one of the
advantages of doing so also is that
sometimes these networks take a long
time to train and someone else might
have used multiple GPUs and the very
large data set to pre-trained so
these networks and that allows you to do
transfer learning using these networks
which we'll discuss in the next video as
well of course if you're computer vision
research are implementing these things
from scratch then your workflow would be
different and if you do that then do
contribute your work back to the open
source community but because so many
vision researchers have done so much
were implementing these architectures I
found that often starting with open
source implementations as a better way
was assert a faster way to get started
on the new project